هل انتم مستعدون للقاء الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان? السؤال
طبيعي في مثل هذه الحالة ما هو
الهدف من اي لقاء سياسي? اليوم
صالحوا الجماعة.
الحضن العربي يستقبل فردا اخر.
سوريا تعود ادراجها. بعد اكثر من
اثني عشر عاما اكل الزمن على
رؤوس السوريين وشرب. انقطعت
علاقة دمشق بشقيقاتها. تشرد
مواطنوها في اصقاع الارض. فمنهم
من مات جائعا ومنهم من قتله
البرد والثلج. ومنهم من استقبله
تجار البشر فاخذوا ما بقي من
اجزاء جسده. فعن اي حال نتحدث.
واليوم ان الاوان لان سوريا
حرائق خلافاتها مع الجيران. حان
وقت الاتحاد ونبذ الصراعات
والفرقة. سوريا تنفض غبار الحروب
والازمات وتستقبل عصر السلم
والحوار. فهل يحدث ذلك حقا? وهل
اقتربت دمشق من طي صفحة الماضي
لتفتح صفحة بيضاء جديدة عن عودة
سوريا للحضن العربي نتحدث?
وللقصة بقية. سوريا تندب حظها.
يا ابن عمي. هكذا قالتها الدول
العربية لسوريا. خطوات عودة
سوريا الى الحضن العربي اكثر ما
يتصدر التطورات الخاصة بالملف
السوري. وما بين تحركات تدار من
خلف الطاولة هي السعودية تؤكدها
رسميا واخرى ترجمتها دولة
الامارات لاكثر من مرة وما
بينهما من مبادرة اردنية وزيارة
مصرية يعيش السوريون امل استعادة
الزمن لاكثر من اثنا عشرة سنة
الى الوراء. حين كانت سوريا
مكتفية بزراعتها وصناعتها بل
ودولة مصدرة. انقلبت الاوضاع
وصار الحال على ما نرى لا على ما
نسمع. نعم لقد اصبح الوضع في
سوريا مأساويا بالمعنى الحرفي
للكلمة يا اصدقاء. لم يكد يستعد
بعضا من عافيته حتى تناولته
الازمات المتضاربة واحدة تلو
الاخرى. تدهور النقد حاد ومن ثم
ارتفاع ضخم للبطالة فقر مدقع حتى
اصبح الحصول على رغيف الخبز
بمثابة حلم لدى المواطن السوري
وان حصل عليه فقد حصلت المعجزة
فضلا عن انعدام الاستقرار
والامن. فيالى حالكم البائس ايها
السوريون. عام الفين واحد عشر
خرج عشرات الالاف في مظاهرات
بالعديد من المدن السورية طالبوا
خلالها باطلاق الحريات والافراج
عن المعتقل السياسيين من السجون
وانهاء حالة الطوارئ ولكن بعد
ذلك دخلت الدولة والمدن والقرى
والبيوت وكل مفاصل الدولة بما هو
اسوأ من حالة الطوارئ. مع مرور
الوقت استمرت المظاهرات وازداد
سقف مطالب المتظاهرين تدريجيا
حتى وصل الى اسقاط نظام بشار
الاسد بالكامل. ليبدأ عام الفين
واثني عشر مع زيادة استعمال
الاسلحة الثقيلة في وقصفت الكثير
من المدن وتشظت الدولة عن بكرة
ابيها. فهل الى رجوع من سبيل
يتسائل السوريون لكن مهلا فالقصة
لم تبدأ بعد. فعلى مدى اثني عشر
عاما ظل الشعب السوري هو الضحية
بين القتل والتهجير والتشريد
والوقوع كفريسة للتدخل الاجنبي
والتناحر السياسي والعسكري. فترك
ملايين السوريين بلادهم وانطلقوا
كلاجئين الى دول مجاورة ثم
انتشروا في الارض باحثين عن لقمة
عيش يسدون بها جوعهم وعن مأوى
امن يضعون عوائلهم واطفالهم فيه.
فعن اي مأساة نتحدث عمليات
عسكرية متواصلة قصف وتفجيرات
مستمرة طوال كل هذه السنوات.
اسفر عنها مقتل نحو ستمائة
واربعة عشر الف شخص اصيب اكثر من
مليونين ومائة الف مواطن سوري
جراح مختلفة واعاقات دائمة تشرد
نحو ثلاثة عشر مليون مواطن اخرين
وفقا للمرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان. افلا يكفي ذلك ايها
المتحاربون ايها المتخاصمون ان
اوان توقفكم. وقد سجلت نسب الفقر
في سوريا ارتفاعا غير مسبوق منذ
بداية هذه الاحداث. حيث يعيش
اكثر من تسعين بالمائة من السكان
في حالة فقر مدقع يجدون صعوبة
توفير ابسط الاحتياجات اليومية
والاساسية من مأكل ومشرب وملبس
وعلاج مع ارتفاع مخيف ومجحف
للاسعار. هنا ركب الموجة تجار
البشر ليلتقطوا المهاجرين
السوريين واللاجئين من كل مكان.
والهدف استدراجهم وبيع اعضائهم
ونهب اموالهم. ومن نجا من تجار
البشر مات غرقا خلال هجرته او
لجأ الى دولة اوروبية فضاق ذرعا
بعنصريتهم المقيتة. وكان كل تلك
الحروب الداخلية والاهلية لا
تكفي. فجاء الاجانب والجيران
لياخذوا نصيبهم من الكعكة
السورية. وضربات الكيان
الاسرائيلي لم تتوقف على الاراضي
السورية. عمليات تركيا العسكرية
تستهدف مناطق مختلفة داخل سوريا.
وبينما العالم مشغول بالحرب
الروسية الاوكرانية استغل الخارج
ما يعيشه الداخل السوري حتى ان
حطت بقاعدتها العسكرية في
الاراضي السورية لتشن عملياتها
على مدار العقد الماضي. واستولت
على ابار النفط السورية. وايران
ايضا كان لها في الكعكة نصيب
لتواجه الكيان الاسرائيلي على
اراضي سوريا. فكل من كان له
مشكلة مع احد فليأتي الى سوريا
يا سادة. ففيها ارض لا ترد
متحاربين ابدا. انها ساحة لحروب
الداخل ومستنقع للصراعات
الخارجية فهل من مغيث؟ واما
خاتمة الكوارث وام الفواجع فكان
زلزالا اكل الاخضر واليابس في
بعض المدن السورية وقلب عاديها
سافلها. ولن اتحدث عن عدد القتلى
او المشردين او المتضررين.
فالقلب يندى لهذه الفاجعة. بارقة
الامل. مع كل تلك الاحداث. ادار
العرب ظهورهم لسوريا وشعبها. لكن
لكل انقطاع العودة. وكان العود
احمدا هذه المرة ايها السوريون.
ولاكثر من مرة اعلن الاردن عن
مبادرة عربية للحل في سوريا. وهي
ما رددها وزير الخارجية الاردني
ايمن الصفدي بقوله الحل يتمثل
بقيام العرب بحوار سياسي مع
النظام يستهدف حل الازمة ومعالجة
تداعياتها الامنية والسياسية
والانسانية. وبعد ما كانت ايران
حجر امام اعادة علاقات سوريا
بمحيطها العربي خصوصا علاقات
دمشق بالسعودية. ها هو رئيس
النظام السوري بشار الاسد يؤكد
ان اعلان استئناف العلاقات بين
ايران والسعودية بوساطة صينية هو
مفاجأة رائعة. مهلا مهلا يا هذا
فالمفاجأة لم تحدث بعد. نعم.
فالمصادر السعودية المطلعة
تقولها للعلن بان المملكة ستدعو
بشار الاسد لحضور القات التي
تستضيفها العاصمة الرياض يوم
التاسع عشر من مايو المقبل لتعود
المياه لمجاريها. ليؤكدها الرئيس
الاماراتي محمد بن زايد لنظيره
السوري عودة دمشق الى محيطها
العربي اصبحت ضرورة ملحة. واين
قال ذلك؟ نعم. لقد قالها خلال
استقباله لبشار الاسد وزوجته على
الاراضي الاماراتية. زيارة الاسد
لم تقتصر على الامارات وهي
طائرته تهبط في سلطنة عمان بمشهد
لم يشهده العرب منذ اكثر من عقد.
واما مصر فاتصل رئيسها عبدالفتاح
السيسي ببشار الاسد. اجرى وزير
خارجيته زيارة الى دمشق بعد
كارثة الزلزال لتتبدل العلاقات
من الانقطاع الدائم الى الاتحاد.
ويا له من اتحاد سيجمع العرب صفا
واحدا يا سادة. ليقولها العرب
بصوت واحد يجب الا تترك سوريا
كما في السابق فخلال سنوات مضت
رأينا عدة دول غير عربية تتحكم
بالمصير السوري سواء تركيا او
ايران او روسيا او امريكا او حتى
الكيان الاسرائيلي. فلا فرقة بعد
الان والاحضان العربية مفتوحة
للسوريين. العرب لم يفتحوا
احضانهم للسوريين فقط. بل حطوا
رحالهم في الاراضي السورية. فهنا
وفد من الاتحاد البرلماني العربي
يشمل رؤساء النواب في العراق
والاردن وفلسطين وليبيا ومصر
والامارات اضافة لنواب من سلطنة
عمان ولبنان وبعد عزلة تجاوزت
اثني عشر عاما بسبب الصراع في
البلاد سوريا لم تعد وحيدة. بصيص
الامل السوري لم يكن عربيا وحسب.
فالعاصمة الروسية موسكو شهدت
انعقاد الاجتماع الثلاثي بين كل
من تركيا وسوريا وروسيا في
ديسمبر عام الفين واثنين وعشرين.
بهذا اعادة العلاقات بين الدول
الثلاثة وايجاد مخرج للازمة
السورية ليجمع بوتين شمل من
شتتتهم الولايات المتحدة
الامريكية. بعد سنوات طويلة من
معاناة سوريا من اوضاع متدنية
على كافة الاصعدة مع تدخلات
خارجية حتى اصبحت ساحة لعمليات
الشد والجذب بين القوى المختلفة.
ساحة مليئة بالتخبطات والتشابكات
التي كادت تعلو الام المواطنين.
هي سوريا والمنطقة بشكل عام تشهد
تحولات سياسية كبيرة. فسوريا
عادت الى الحاضنة العربية واتفقت
ايران والسعودية. فهل هذه
التحولات هي من ستعيد العرب الى
سابق عهده?